a fennel sausage frittata
[Music]
the exciting thing about frittata is the
fact there's no set recipe because it's
basically eggs whatever else you have
left
for me the secret of a good frittata
is in the sausage
nice hot pan onions in
genus on the onions heat
nice and high
season
fennel seeds to give the onions
a really nice flavor everyone's used to
cooking sausages whole
but it's a really nice way of
using them to take them out of their
thin skin
what we're going to do is crumple all
that wonderful spicy fennel sausage into
the onions it's going to release all
that flavor a lot quicker
pretty important to keep that gas nice
and high
and the longer you caramelise the
sausage the more flavor
you're going to gain
six whole eggs
give your eggs a really good mix
flat leaf parsley a staple in italian
cooking chop it
quite rough
some parmesan
it gives a really nice seasoning fresh
pepper
a little touch of salt
and then get it in there
when you fork through it so when you
slice it no one's complaining they've
got less sausage
i'm gonna make it even more italian by
topping it
with some buffalo mozzarella
dry it and then slice it nice and thinly
twist it
mozzarella
in
and then finally finish it with that
pounds and cheese get the top just as
tasty as the bottom
my frittata needs three and a half to
four minutes under a red hot grill to
achieve the best results always ensure
your oven or grill are preheated to the
perfect temperature
she's ready
this is the thing i love about italian
cooking it's about sharing but always
focusing on the ingredients
look at that
i mean it's incredible
a little shake the pan to make sure it
comes out and then spatula underneath
and just leave it
it's light
fluffy and it smells
incredible and that for me is a dream
come true it's amazing how far you can
take six eggs and two sausages
wow
spicy fennel sausage frittata my
ultimate italian breakfast
it's a cracking start to the day
[Music]
i go fishing a lot and scotch eggs are
the perfect all-in-one mini picnic
breakfast first thing get your eggs
cooked bring the water up the boil onto
the spoon
and lower them into the water that way
they don't hit the water and crack
four and a half minutes that'll keep the
center
nice and slightly runny
now
ground sausage meat i'm gonna make mine
a little bit spicier i'm gonna crumble
in black pudding
that helps to season the scotch eggs
inside a little touch of salt and pepper
and then just to make it a little bit
sweeter and a lot easier for the kids to
eat some grated apple
[Music]
combine that blend in the apple and the
black pudding
eggs once they're cooked drain them and
then run them under cold water
cracking and cooling the eggs quickly
will prevent the yolks turning gray
tap them on the side of the pan
put them back into the water and what
happens the water seeps underneath the
shell
see the shell come off so much easier
eggs still slightly soft in the center i
want that little bit of richness with
the yolk
next you need to get yourself organized
with a mini assembly line
seasoned flour
a little egg wash
and breadcrumbs
take
your mince golf ball size
spread the pate manipulate with your
thumb
and then
sit your egg in there
and spread
the sausage over the egg
and you just seal that over
really important to keep that nice even
coating of sausage meat around the egg
you don't want it too thick otherwise it
gets too dense and it's unappetizing
give them a light dusting in the
seasoned flour
if you don't put the flour on the egg
wash won't stick if you don't put the
egg wash on the breadcrumbs won't stick
into the egg
roll it round
shake off
any excess egg wash and roll it into
your breadcrumbs you can use this same
three-stage method to breadcrumb
anything you'd like from chicken goujons
and fish fillets to fina schnitzel these
are panko breadcrumbs japanese white
breadcrumb so no crust
you can experiment by adding flavors to
your breadcrumbs like parmesan herbs or
citrus zest
i always like to push the actual
breadcrumbs into the sausage meat so it
gets that really nice golden brown and
stops any of the outside burning
once breadcrumbed lower the eggs
carefully into a four centimeter deep
bath of hot vegetable oil for 10 to 12
minutes
the eggs are actually cooked
soft and running the center so the
objective is just to cook the sausage
meat and the black pudding
they're great don't they go and grenades
there's something so magical about a
scotch egg on a picnic because it's like
this little mini breakfast
beautiful
drain them onto the paper roll them
around
just to get off any excess oil and then
to transport them
some greaseproof paper
that for me is the perfect start to the
fishing trip there's no wonder i never
catch any fish
because i'm always too busy eating my
scotch eggs
[Music]
my ultimate black pudding lace scotch
eggs an irresistibly delicious picnic
breakfast
pear and crunchy granola muffins
something quite nice when you walk into
friends or family's house and you smell
a muffin being baked the flour and the
baking powder in
a nice touch of cinnamon
cinnamon muffins goes brilliantly a
pinch of salt that's really important
for the sort of overall flavor you don't
want the muffin to be too sweet
muscovado sugar that's a refined brown
sugar really rich
somewhat spicy and goes brilliantly
inside the muffin
and then my crispy granola now i'm gonna
put half of this in now and save the
other half just sprinkle on top of the
muffin
give that a really good mix
in the center i'll have some fresh pear
top and tail the pears
really important to peel nothing worse
when you're trying to enjoy that muffin
and you're negotiating with a big sliver
of skin of pear
slice them round the core
four sides
and slice it nice and thinly
generally muffins contain around half
the fat and sugar of cupcakes
once the dry ingredients are mixed
together you add in the wet
two whole eggs
nice milk in
followed by gently melted butter
give that a good mix
[Music]
add that to your mixture
just start folding
always do it by hand muffins are
delicate dainty little beasts
don't overwork your muffin mixture you
want that mixture to become nice and
relaxed
now the mix looks nice and creamy
your tray
and your little cups
and spoon in that mixture
two thirds full
one nice generous spoon
you can tell the mix is right because
you've got that even distribution of the
pear running from the top to the bottom
just gently tap your tray both ends
that gets the mix all the way down so
they cook nice and evenly
take your granola now sprinkle that on
top so you got this dual texture spicy
pear
and this nice crunchy topping makes the
muffin taste and feel a little bit more
luxurious
now into the oven at 180 for 25 minutes
beauties
[Music]
they smell delicious
you got that nice crispy
top just get them out and let them cool
down
and i don't have any problems turning
vegetarian once or twice a week
when i'm having muffins like that
nice
i smell amazing
[Music]
a vegetarian breakfast to put hairs on
your chest pear and crunchy granola
muffins
that is a vegetarian delight beautiful
eggs bait in hash browns
the secret of a great hash brown
are the potatoes
i prefer using really nice waxy potatoes
they cook better but more importantly
hold themselves together
we're not gonna slice the onion all the
potatoes but we're actually gonna grate
them the potatoes get really nice and
crispy i mean seriously crispy now the
onion
that way you get that nice
balance of the onion flavor running
through
every little shard of potato
[Music]
season with salt pepper olive oil and km
give that a really good mix through
and then squeeze
all that water out
and look at all that juice we squeeze
out there
really important the more liquid you
remove the crispier your hash browns
will be
nice large pan put that on
once the pan's hot pour in a good glug
of olive oil
[Music]
that sound confirms
how important it is to have your pan
nice and hot
so it seals
the grated potato onion together
so take the spoon
and just
pat it down what we're trying to do now
is get it really nice and compact
going around the outside of the pan with
little flecks of butter you just slip
them down the back gently
and that gets the onions caramelised
here's a great tip for turning your hash
browns over quick and easy take a plate
place it on top and just
flip it over
and then slide it back in
very quickly
you see the color
we've got on there now
you've got that nice
crispy texture
of the potato i'm going to use the hash
brown as a bed for my baked eggs
crack in your eggs nice and gently just
a little sprinkling of the cayenne
to make the eggs a little bit spicy then
into a preheated oven for six to eight
minutes meanwhile onto my bacon and i'm
giving it a classic american twist now
one thing i could never get my head
around when i first started eating lots
of american breakfast was the sweetness
from the bacon i've grown up to love
that combination of smoky sweet flavors
and it's so easy
pan on and simply olive oil brown sugar
salt and pepper and butter
bacon in and as it cooks it becomes
irresistibly caramelized and golden
brown
top of gas
and my glazed bacon
absolutely ready
beautiful
now my hash browns and baked eggs are
ready
wow
look at that
beautiful just
put your spatula underneath there
onto your plate
and that bacon
sets beauty on top of the baked eggs and
that hash brown underneath and
you can see why
the best breakfasts in the world are
always in america
this is an all-american superhero offer
breakfast eggs bait in hash browns with
glazed bacon
you